no sé extraño que dentro de alguna
semana vamos a iniciar una campaña pero
agresiva a fondo como dije
para difundir todos estos métodos de la
planificación familiar así comenzó el
que era un plan del gobierno que tenía
como objetivo combatir la pobreza a
través del control de la natalidad una
esterilización masiva que se estima se
aplicó a unas 350 mil mujeres de las
cuales más de dos mil denuncia que
fueron sometidas sin su consentimiento y
en algunos casos con amenazas la
fiscalidad reconocía más de 1300
víctimas en medio de este proceso que
este 11 de enero vivió un importante
giro aunque el ente acusador comenzó en
2003 las investigaciones apenas hasta
ahora dio inicio una audiencia por este
caso tras varios episodios de archivo es
el caso más antiguo no es el único pero
están logrando llegar por primera vez al
poder judicial 1.307 de antes
de las cuales hay cinco denunciantes
víctimas mortales el ex presidente
alberto fujimori quien se encuentra en
una cárcel de lima y su ex ministro de
salud figuran entre los denunciados
desde el ejecutivo de entonces mantienen
que estás esterilizaciones fueron
consentidas y es lamentable que el
gobierno imaginó tener un compromiso con
nosotras como víctimas porque somos
víctimas prestaciones porque hemos sido
seleccionadas nuestro cuerpo nuestro
espíritu de acuerdo con las denunciantes
ese plan se centró sobre todo en la
comunidad indígena con víctimas que en
algunos casos eran únicamente dicho
hablantes